انظر ، ما زلت أحصل على كتلة الكاتب في
بعض الأحيان ، يتعين علي أحيانًا كتابة
الخطب التي تعرفها الخطب الكبيرة وأنا
أجلس هناك وأفكر أنني لا
أعرف ما أريد أن أقوله حيث
أعرف أحيانًا ما أريد أن أقوله ولكن
لا أعرف كيف أقولها أو كيف أبدأها
بشكل صحيح ، لذا لا يمكنك أن تخاف
من أنك في كثير من الأحيان
سبب حظر الأشخاص هو
أنهم قلقون بشأن ما سأفعله
لن يكون هذا جيدًا جيدًا ،
لا شيء جيد جدًا في المرة الأولى التي
تفعل فيها ذلك ، فأنت تعلم أن مسودتك الأولى هي أن
الجميع هنا يتعلم
كيف تعرف في فصول اللغة الإنجليزية الخاصة بك
أنك تكتب المسودات بشكل صحيح وأنت تحاول
شيئًا تكتبه  في المرة الأولى التي
تستمع فيها حتى إلى أفضل الكتاب ، عادة ما يكون
الأمر غير جيد في المرة الأولى التي
يكتبون فيها ذلك ، وأعتقد أنك
غطيت كل شيء عن هذا السؤال ،
حسنًا ، أعتقد أنني سأفكر في
معظم الأمهات أنني كنت أتحدث أيضًا
منذ فترة طويلة لا أعتقد أنك الآن فقط دعنا
نتحرك
يا إلهي